welcome to the New York Stock Exchange
tell us about this place well it's a
very special place in America's history
and in the world's financial markets
this is the 206th year of our operations
and yet Brian almost 70 percent of the
companies that were privileged to trade
today weren't here a decade ago so while
in one sense we're almost as old as this
great nation itself whereas new as some
of the emerging great growth companies
that are joining us it's an institution
that really serves the American
population directly there are some 60
million shareholders in the United
States and when you measure indirect
ownership perhaps as many as 200 million
Americans have a stake in what happens
here each day as you can see on the
screen right now it's dark and there
aren't many lights down there and there
aren't many people down there when does
this all come to life well it begins to
come alive at about 7:30 7:45 when all
of the technologists do the final check
on this infrastructure we've got a
network here that we've built over the
last 7 or so years that on an average
day handles some 640 million shares but
has the capacity to handle in excess of
2 billion shares so the technologists
arrived to do the final screening of our
our systems to make sure they're hot and
prepared for the day's activity the
professionals begin to arrive at about 8
o'clock
of course the excitement this morning
you will see beginning at 9:30 when the
officers of Cary diversified ring the
opening bell on the screen right now is
our set which is above the floor here
and it's coming from one of your own row
boat cameras that you have in and around
the stock exchange some nine cameras
that you establish there since 1996 in
the new facility why do you do this well
this is such an important part of every
American's life the marketplace itself
has become the pool of savings for most
Americans those who are planning for
retirement those who are funding
children's education is funding health
care and shelter needs so it is really
mainstream America today and we wanted
to bring the New York Stock Exchange to
the American people in a live format so
that everyone can better know how the
marketplace works the merits of
investing for the long term and most
importantly get to know the New York
Stock Exchange a little better hello
you've been chairman I've been chairman
since 1995 I was appointed in October of
94 but I've been here for 30 years Brian
where's your home or Rizzoli home is
originally here in New York right here
in the sit on the groan I actually grew
up in Queens I want to ask you about
something over my left shoulder and
we'll get a shot of it in just a moment
but it's a flag that hangs out over the
stock exchange and you can see it on the
screen there it says P o WM IA and at
the bottom you are not forgotten why is
this hanging over the exchange well as
you will experience Brian in your visit
today there is an enormous patriotism
amongst the membership and staff of the
NYC this marketplace has basically been
the platform for capital formation for
the building of the American economy
yet each November we recognize on the
11th day at the 11th hour those who
fought to make certain that our way of
life would continue and there is
literally not a dry eye in this room
everyone on this trading floor stops for
two minutes on Veterans Day those who
were lost in the conflict in Southeast
Asia of the Vietnam conflict are
remembered today and continue to be in
the hearts and minds of everyone here so
we fly that flag very proudly as a
remembrance of those who allow us and
privilege us to do what we do today
we're gonna have our phone lines open
throughout these three hours and we've
got callers coming in right now to talk
to Richard Grasso who's the chairman and
CEO of the New York Stock Exchange why
don't we go to phones and begin the
process of finding out what's on the
minds of people that watching first call
is from Raleigh North Carolina go ahead
please you're on with chairman Grasso
all right Bryan you do a great job and
don't let the people who tell you that
you didn't do
great job on the Tocqueville thanks
welcome I know you back from the time
that you had been at the stock exchange
six years and Bill Brantley from X from
ball corporation and Lowe's companies hi
Bill how are you well I'm doing okay my
friend do I still hold the indoor and
outdoor record on the person who's
participated in the most listings
well you're right up there in the circle
of Champions bill what does that mean
caller well I I was with to public
companies when and handled their listing
on the New York Stock Exchange and then
when I went out practicing on my own I
think I listed five more of my clients
on the stock exchange and even the last
one on this Stock Exchange is an immense
thing to do and a real feather in your
cap well thanks for the call let me ask
you about listing how does it happen
that somebody can be listed on the New
York's document well Brian we've got a
team of professionals who recruit
companies both on the domestic side and
on the international side there are in
America today some 750 or so
corporations traded on other markets
that do qualify to trade on the New York
Stock Exchange so we've got a team of
professionals out there trying to court
their affections on the international
side we've got a team that follow more
than 3,000 companies perhaps as many as
2400 that are fully qualified right now
what we do is we introduce the merits
the benefits of listing on this exchange
realize that this is the world's largest
equities market and for a corporation
that's planning to raise capital
planning to grow its business planning
to expand through acquisition or merger
this becomes the ideal setting the ideal
platform to carry out those strategic
plans so we bring the message and the
values of listing to an exchange of to
those corporations that are qualified
and when we're fortunate enough as we
are today to bring Cary diversified we
introduced the company by the ringing of
the opening bell by the way it's
normally this platform where a camera
sits that shoots right down on the floor
and we'll show you this in just a moment
we're the CNBC reporters stand to give
their reports on CNBC later on we'll be
able to show you how the CNN does it on
the other side and that this is only one
of four rooms how close to the other
three rooms well they're contiguous one
of the original rooms is behind the wall
that's in back of you Brian than to our
behind the wall and back of me
the rooms themselves are identical
though in technology we've completely
refitted the infrastructure in the last
five years replacing virtually every
piece of technology on that trading
floor so as to provide a marketplace
that as we saw last October can handle
more - than the billion shares in a
single session without breaking a sweat
for our normal audience as the morning
goes on you'll notice that our voice
will undoubtedly be raised because of
the voice level in here and the noise
level was raised but for the moment we
get a voice from Ellijay Georgia from
their voice go ahead please yes Brian
great show I would like to ask mr.
Grasso about the IMF bailout I got a
call from Pat Buchanan he strongly
opposed to a taxpayer bailout of
Southeast Asia I noticed saw on c-span
this morning Steve Forbes is against and
I'd like to ask mr. Grasso
deceased the fourth IMF bailout of South
of Asia I think it is absolutely
essential that we both in the private
sector and from the public perspective
the government the IMF do all that we
can to help stabilize those economies
that are in trouble right now recognize
that the future trading partners for our
nation are those very countries that are
in need of our help and therefore I
believe it's important for us to support
the IMF initiatives it is equally
important for those countries to adopt
proper and strong measures that will
stabilize their economies the
initiatives that the IMF will hold as
the quid pro quo for the bailout
packages and so I do indeed support the
initiatives because I think it's
important to the future of our economy
as an exporter to that part of the world
how many people actually work for your
operation here the parent company has
fourteen hundred and seventy five
partners employees Brian the technology
subsidiary which is two thirds owned by
the stock exchange has another fourteen
hundred and our trust company which
operates independently as more than two
thousand employees you hear about the
Dow Jones Industrials how many stocks
are a part of that index there are
thirty listed securities that comprise
the Dow Jones Industrials and actually
over the course of the 102 years of
existence of that index the names have
changed to reflect the changes in our
economy the only constant over those 102
years the company the last remaining
original component is the General
Electric Company all thirty of those
companies belong to the New York Stock
Exchange they do indeed and we're very
proud of that we have a camera on the
other side just to show the audience how
the other networks do when they cover
here as a matter of fact on your screen
right now is one of your Robo cameras
that are up on the wall looking at Bill
Heffley and Eric Hanson our folks down
on the floor and though as they pull
back you'll be able to see now the
camera as it is on the wall and that's
where the CNN reporters stand how long
have you allowed that to happen live on
the floor during the trading well it's
been about three years now Brian and
it's been an absolute delight for us the
professional talent from CNN has done a
spectacular job of bringing the
marketplace to the viewers of that
network and I think it's become a very
important source of information a source
of Education for American investors so
we're thrilled with what the network's
have done Warwick Rhode Island you're
next go ahead please you're on with
Richard Grasso chairman and CEO of the
New York Stock Exchange
good morning mr. Grasso good morning I
just like to say I'd like to
congratulate you on a job well done
I left my field about five years ago as
a social worker to become a day trader
I'm a New York Stock Exchange right in
my home congratulations thank you very
much I trade right over the Internet I
have made tremendous amount of money I'm
a New York Stock Exchange
it's the old-fashioned American dream
and I my question to you is how do you
feel about this last merger that just
happened with the two
drug companies as worth what over fifty
million dollars well I think you're
referring to the possible combination of
SmithKline Beecham and American Home
Products which was talked about in the
in the press yesterday and today it
would obviously create the largest
pharmaceutical consumer products company
in the world they've yet to actually
propose the transaction but many believe
many of the analytical community who
follow the pharmaceutical industry
believe that this is the first of a
number of very large combinations is our
caller still on the line what did you
say you used to do before he became a
traitor I used to be a social worker I
have a master's degree in social work
and I really seen not too much I fear a
future but I did not see a financial
need where where the growth of my
financial need to grow a family was
gonna take off in that field and I
started off mr. grassle buying 50 shares
of stock at $12 now mr. glass shall I
buy blocks at a time did you say you
trade on the Internet absolutely mr.
Grasso how much of this kind of thing is
happening now with the internet so
active well technology has really
exported the floor of the New York Stock
Exchange to potentially millions of
investors who choose to trade online
Brian the the system itself that we've
built actually links point of access to
the trading floor and on an average day
we do perhaps as much as 82 percent of
our transactions over our own version of
the Internet we call it our super dot
system those orders come to us from a
broker's terminal anywhere in the world
are introduced executed and back on that
brokers terminal in 22 seconds that can
be more than 80 percent of our trades
each day producing about 40 percent of
our share volume what many of our firms
have done is export their technology
into the homes of their customers and so
I believe our caller
is really one of those interface type
traders who's fully appreciated that
technology can bring him from wherever
in the world to the floor of the
exchange in nanoseconds edie qua Wasser
of the New York Stock Exchange will join
us in a few moments he is the government
relations official and he spent 17 years
with the Securities and Exchange
Commission before coming here we go to
Warwick
I'm sorry York Pennsylvania you're next
good morning mr. Grasso and Brian one
thing that's just very very interesting
I've been diddling in stocks for years
and my question is how much do you know
how much it costs to revitalize your
computer systems and and your internet
and all that well over the over the
course of the last 10 or so years we've
spent about two billion dollars which
would be roughly a billion and a half on
operating and processing technologies
and about a half a billion on regulatory
technologies follow-up question New York
hardened you have another question yeah
I don't know all this question it's a
statement probably how could you get
your technicians to get together with
the IRS because they've spent I don't
know how many billions and they can't
get their computers working thanks
caller let's go to next call Asheville
North Carolina
you're on with Richard Grasso yes good
morning mr. Grasso good morning welcome
and good morning to you all so Bryan you
do a wonderful job up there thanks sir I
watch your programs quite regularly
during the weekend I wish I had one
thing that I'm looking at now but I wish
I had closed captioning we're working on
that someday soon we'll have it I hope
I'm sure you will mr. Grasso my comment
is while not being a Vietnam veteran I
am a navy veteran I was too young for
Korea and to of of Vietnam but I wanted
a comment say I'm very proud of you
people putting that flag they're very
proud thank you very much we're proud to
fly it it means a lot to me my brother
lost her mind white brother lost her
brother in Vietnam but my other question
is I see Old Glory flying there very
proudly do you show apply any of the
type of veteran flags and
exchange well actually on the observance
of Veterans Day we stopped the market at
11 o'clock and we have various plaques
remembering those from the financial
community who have served in the Armed
Forces and given made the ultimate
sacrifice I hope one day you are in New
York on Veterans Day and you can come to
our visitors center and actually observe
it it's the most touching moment of the
year for us thanks a lot lady with the
veterans and I belong to ambit but again
I'm very proud to see that black line
they're very proud thanks Connor next
call Los Angeles good morning good
morning yes my name is Mohammed I'm
calling in regards to the circuit break
and I was wondering isn't this actually
against the capitalist system where the
system is hands-off and here due to the
Black Monday now we've got this closing
down of the stock market to cause the
prices to come back to normal and if mr.
Grasso could comment on this and if he
could comment on the capitalist ideology
fitting in it with the stock exchange
Thanks long sayings let me ask mr.
Grasso to define what a circuit breaker
is a circuit breaker is a temporary
interruption in trading Brian designed
when markets are dramatically lower to
provide a timeout so that small
investors particularly can take a deep
breath and rigs them and whether indeed
they want to enter orders or they want
to simply let the marketplace take its
own course to the callers observation we
of course are the bastion of free
markets here but we do believe we have a
public responsibility a ten percent
decline in the marketplace is roughly
800 downs it took the Dow Jones
Industrial Average --is 70 years to get
to a thousand so what we are offering is
a brief timeout a 60 minute timeout when
the marketplace has such a dramatic fall
so that investors can regroup its
thing more than that and it certainly is
not designed to prevent the market from
finding its natural level for Richard
Grasso from the New York Stock Exchange
we got a Logansport Indiana good morning
good morning it's such a pleasure to
talk to you once again mr. Grasso the
patriotism I have seen you display is
absolutely beautiful it's so refreshing
and it's just what our country needs to
be appreciative of all that have gone
before in our servicemen and as you can
tell I am proud to be an American and
I'm very concerned about the our
veterans our Vietnam veterans and I have
written a special book called red white
and true and in there I have a special
point for Vietnam veterans this poem has
been read at the Vietnam War Memorial in
Washington DC and also I have a special
little essay called what is freedom
anyway and in there I pay special
attention and say that the POWs and
those missing in actions they know what
freedom is and they know what freedom is
not collar thanks for this call and I
want to ask because we've got a couple
other ones are you surprised how many
people called immediately about the mi
APO W flag how did all Brian I think
this is a very special time as we
approach the millennium for Americans to
remember those who got us through these
first 200 years of our our nation's
history and we are very proud I hope
that caller who mentioned the poem will
send me that poem because I'll
distribute it to all of my colleagues
and partners on the floor of the
exchange
speaking of tradition with your bell
ringing that goes on every day at 9:30
is our limit to who can ring the bell
well we we oftentimes have the
the very difficulty at delightful
problem of having more than one customer
here for the opening of trading today
we've got only one so it will be our new
customer and we can see that on the
screen just a moment the spot up there
who can't ring it in other words is
there a restriction on who's allowed to
well it's normally reserved for new
customers VIP heads of state those from
the membership who are retiring Brian
special guests we want it to be a
special event because the opening of the
market of the closing of the market each
day is seen by literally a hundred
million viewers and that's a very
special audience that we want to portray
a message to that is not routine
I want to thank Tony Valenti who is in
charge of the broadcast facility here
for helping us and his staff and if we
didn't have him we probably wouldn't be
able to make it on the air I feel the
same way Brian we're here for the rest
of the morning live with Richard Grasso
for the next few minutes the New York
Stock Exchange floor our next call from
Rosamund california go ahead please yes
mr. Grasso I I heard earlier you were
saying about the bailout on the Asian
Asian countries the IMF said that these
are our trading partners well I don't
know now I'm sure there might have been
other ones but the last one I know that
we bill that was Mexico you know whether
after we build Mexico out our trading
deficit increased or decreased well I
believe the and good morning I believe
it was very important to do what our
government did when Mexico saw the the
crisis that it experienced three years
ago and I believe it's equally important
in our government has taken the proper
initiatives through the IMF and directly
to make certain that those countries
that are going to receive financial aid
packages develop a strict set of
disciplines designed to put their
economies back on strong footing but it
is important and I think you raise a
very a very worthwhile example look at
the wonderful job that Mexico has done
at repositioning itself and stimulating
trade with the United State
since our our rescue plan I want to show
you I think we still have this shot of
something on the floor of the exchange
if you look over here on the monitor
this is a chair or a stool that sits out
there and it's locked down forever with
that big chain why is that necessary on
the floor of the New York Stock Exchange
well Brian chairs are an awfully
valuable commodity on the exchange and
they're really only permitted on the
floor for those who have special
physical needs we don't want anyone
borrowing a chair from from their
neighbors because it is such a heavily
populated environment that we can only
have a few of them down there and
they're only for those with physical
need and so the chains are a little bit
a little bit part of the necessity of
life for Richard Grasso we go to Trenton
New Jersey next go ahead please Vavoom
Brian good morning good morning welcome
this one a bringing of coin I've never
heard discussed and that would be street
expectations I'd like to know I think a
lot of people out here like to now how
are these determined and who determines
them I'm sorry you're going to have to
repeat that question you know we're
getting a lot of noise in our background
go ahead and repeat the question caller
okay the question is and I'm sure a lot
of people are out here including myself
would like to know how Street
expectations are derived and who are the
people that sets these figures and how
do they come up with a well each
respective part of our economy
industrial sector is followed by
analysts people who specialize in
knowing in depth the companies and the
industries that they are specializing in
and those analysts those experts become
Street consensus they publish to their
clients and to the world at large the
expectations of earnings based on their
own analysis of the companies and the
industry and the overall economy and
that becomes the so-called street
consensus forecast what was your first
job here I was a trainee Brian it was a
trainee in our
in our what we term stock watching area
which was part of our corporate group
spent about sixteen years in the
corporate group and then moved to the
operating side in nineteen eighty four
Pace University graduate in accounting
and then went to Harvard to do some
special training what year was the
advanced management program at Harvard I
did in the years 1984 and 85 and it was
a it was a program for senior level
executives who were as they say in the
period of career change on the screen we
have a picture of a tough on dangling as
it was yesterday at the end of the
trading day and as the camera goes up
bill Heffley will show us that there's a
bunch of phones on that post there in
the middle of the trading floor what are
those used for those are the phones
Brian that brokers use to communicate
with their assistants who are on the
perimeter of the trading floor you
notice throughout the the perimeter of
the four rooms there are communications
facilities where operations assistants
and trading assistants are receiving
orders to buy and sell listed securities
rather than leaving a trading crowd in
each of our 3,000 companies has one and
only one location we're all trading in
that stock must occur rather than
leaving the trading crowd a broker can
go to a very close by what we call a
yellow phone Bank and call their
assistants to give them updates on
executions we're going to learn about
specialists and traders and all that as
the morning goes on but first for
Richard Grasso Chicago Illinois you're
on the line good morning good morning
what do you think is the social
responsibility of of the Wall Street
firms I just happened to watch a program
on the public you know PBS and it showed
that that like the the Scott company was
kind of this this this member because of
the CEO just trying to fit up the price
of the stock and just practically
destroyed the company what's what's your
opinion on that that type of stuff well
there is clearly a responsibility to be
a good corporate citizen whether you're
in the financial services business
or virtually any other part of our
economy one side to the financial
community to Wall Street that too often
people do not get to see is the enormous
generosity there is no good cause that
comes to the door of this institution
that doesn't get some form of help
literally over the last five years
whether it's charities that benefit
children that promote education that
help those who are homeless that those
who are really down on their on their
luck virtually feeding people at
Thanksgiving or at Christmastime there
is an enormous Liebig heart in the
financial community and I believe
corporations in general in the United
States have embraced a social
responsibility to give back to help
those communities and those people who
are most in need of help that is not
just good from a moral fiber standpoint
it's good business sense because if we
can help those who are down on their
luck eventually they become once again
part of our producing economy I'm gonna
talk to a lot of people before this day
and this week is over here in New York
City
tomorrow and on Friday you'll meet
people like Hugh Downs and Morley Safer
also Larry Kirschbaum who runs war books
adam bellow who has been a editor at
Free Press the other one of the other
publishers it's under the Simon &
Schuster label in addition to that Greg
Tobin will join us for about a half an
hour talk about the Book of the Month
Club books and money and Wall Street and
newspapers and commerce all for the rest
of the week on c-span is Washington
journal Brownsburg Indiana our next call
go ahead please good morning Cuba
morning morning yeah Alan Greenspan has
been such a significant factor in what
the stock market has done today I was
wondering what do you have planned to do
and if that's you know he does plan on
retiring that someday I'm sure
thanks caller well I think you
underscore something we all feel in the
funny
community chairman Greenspan has been an
extraordinary leader of the Federal
Reserve his leadership over the last
decade has truly been right at the top
of the list in terms of those who have
headed the Federal Reserve his absolute
unwavering commitment to making certain
this economy does not read my an
inflationary spiral similar to what we
saw in the late 70s early 80s has made
the difference for so many Americans and
for the strength and health of our
economy in our markets I can only hope
that when that time comes and hopefully
it will be a long time from now that
there is a person in the wings of equal
capacity to chairman Greenspan well this
Wednesday morning there are a few people
that are down on the floor and we've got
our cameras down there to show what
activity there is what's the rule can
people come on here 24 hours a day if
they wanted to hang around their booth
down there not really Brian the the
normal hours you would expect to see a
professional or a an operation support
person or a trading assistant would be
roughly 7:00 in the morning through
about 6:00 at night after that the floor
must be cleared because we're doing a
lot of technology changes that need to
be tested implemented a lot of
infrastructure retooling goes on in the
off hours so we really don't want the
professionals here other than in the
period that we expect them to be doing
it where's the blue jackets well you
actually can't tell what that particular
gentleman's role is until you read his
badge because office coats the different
colored coats are worn by some that are
members those that are trading
assistants that particular gentleman is
what we refer to as a trading assistant
he's the person who stands behind the
dealer and supports the dealer our
dealers are known as specialists he
supports the dealer and keeping him
abreast of the informational flow his
trading counts his position counts kind
of is like a trader in training to calls
left for Richard Grasso and then we'll
be joined by Edward qual Wasser who is
the government relations
and for the New York Stock Exchange San
Francisco you're next go ahead please
good morning Brian
hi good morning Richard good morning I'm
20 years old and I'm currently the
proprietor of a large music music Center
and I'd like to get seriously involved
in trading and I was wondering if you
could recommend any quality book to get
me started
thanks well I would only say this choose
a broker very carefully investigate that
brokers background and please do not
expect to become a trader overnight and
compound the types of gains that we've
seen in the stock market over the last
three years investing requires a lot of
work a lot of investigation and most
importantly a time horizon approach
those who think they're going to make
that so-called quick killing over night
are absolutely mistaken it's a terribly
wrong strategy one that you should not
pursue find a quality broker any member
organization of the New York Stock
Exchange do your homework and set your
goals and from that I think you'll be
pleasantly surprised at the returns also
wanted a recommendation a good book I'd
recommend any one of yours Brian how
about a book about the stock exchange
about trading about this whole business
that you're involved in is there a good
one there are several very good books on
the history of the institution there are
many books on trading strategies and the
strategies virtually differ as
technology changes the shape of the
marketplace I would say the primers on
the New York Stock Exchange on investing
Graham and Dodd certainly the whole
theory of fundamental investing any of
those a good reference librarian will
help you with but most importantly
you've got to recognize the trading as
distinguished from investing is a
moment-by-moment thing to be practiced
by the professional investors who have
done best in the 20th century are those
who take a long horizon approach
last call for Richard Grasso aventura
florida good morning good morning come
quite surprised that you're talking
about books that's what I was gonna call
you about but some books that were
written in the 1970s by one called
Richard may I think you should be
familiar with mr. nice books mr. May
almost said that the stock exchange was
manipulated by the specialists that the
stocks in that go up haphazardly they
were controlled by the motions of the
specialists into 25 years since then
that I've been watching it I'm not a big
investor in the market I find nothing in
the stock market to dispel any of these
accusations thanks Karl
well I think I would have to take issue
with that because on an average day this
marketplace receives roughly 80% of its
transactional content meaning virtually
80 shares out of every hundred that
trade trade without the specialist
intervention the specialist is the
counterbalancing wheel to the
marketplace buying when there are no
buyers selling when there are no sellers
but stepping out of the market to let
the public meet the public when there is
interaction at close pricing levels to
the last sale so well you may think that
mr. Mays book has yet to be refuted I
would say to you that time and again
there have been independent academic
studies professing this to be the best
model for trading for listed securities
the specialist being simply a passive
force in the marketplace and most proud
of my of the fact that the specialist
system today is larger than ever before
better capitalized and providing that
needed source of liquidity when there is
an absence in the marketplace do you
trade here you're so light rate Murph
Ryan but do you buy stocks I do in the
one public company whose board I sit on
and I only buy I never sell my other
investments are done
through independent vehicles so that I'm
not an active participant what's the
company that you board you sit on it's a
company called Computer Associates and
how many members do you have on your
board there are 27 seats on the board
half of those are occupied by people who
are not in the securities business truly
public directors those that had
companies that we're privileged to trade
those that come from all walks of life
other than the securities business
designed so that the governance process
of the New York Stock Exchange is very
similar to that of any company that we
trade on this board our guest Richard
Grasso chairman and CEO of the New York
Stock Exchange thank you for allowing us
to come here thank you Brian come back
and join us again a pleasure to have you